[Musique]
novembre 2019 c'est la course contre la
montre un jeune infirmier disparaît en
forêt en route vers le nord du québec le
mercure chute des policiers et des
bénévoles et des chasseurs autochtone
partent à sa recherche
on ne trouve sur des pistes humain il
faut que ont reçu quelques slows sa
camionnette est localisée suspendu dans
le vide sur un pont en ruines
cette cité connue des alpes ont été
faites par quelqu'un et ça a été laissée
là où finalement entretenu pour rien qui
il est arrivé ce qui est arrivé
giorgi 29 ans a emprunté un des milliers
de chemins forestiers un piètre état qui
parcourt le québec
la majorité des 474 milles kilomètres de
chemins ne sont pas entretenus des
comptes publics sans surveillance
parfois dangereuses voire meurtrières
bon un non sens dans le fait qu'on
construise des chemins de très grande
qualité puis en parallèle on les
abandonne donc donc à l'échelle de la
forêt québécoise devant nous un immense
réseau qui dépérit non seulement ces
infrastructures délabrées menace la
sécurité
elles sont aussi un danger pour
l'environnement des milliers de ponceaux
défaillant arraché bloquer ou a fait ces
saccages nos cours d'eau à l'abri des
regards une fois les opérations
forestières terminé
on parle des chemins puis des ponceaux
je pense qu'on voit la pointe de
l'iceberg du dommage à l'environnement
qui sont ni évoluer ni connu ni perçu du
jury
aux quatre coins du québec des gens
dénoncent cette gestion qui ne tient pas
la route et l'infirmier giorgi on est
devenu le symbole malgré lui bienvenue
dans le far west du québec
depuis un an on a sillonné la province
pour enquêter sur nos forêts des chemins
forestiers on en a vu et on en a
parcouru été comme hiver dans presque
toutes les régions et toutes les
conditions et cette histoire si la plus
triste qui nous a été racontée
du lot de ses 29 ans l'infirmier giorgy
rêvait d'un monde meilleur
du monde s'attacher à lui il y avait 1
était charismatique y avait un grand
coeur puis il prenait soin déjà c'est
dans les communautés cries de la baie
james qu'il tentait de faire une
différence apprenant même un peu leur
langue
le 20 novembre 2019 il quitte brossard
et entreprend son troisième voyage dans
le nord il doit d'abord traversé
l'abitibi et dormir à matagami au volant
de sa camionnette 9 djordje parle avec
son meilleur ami qui veulent lui aussi
infirmiers
bon il commence à neiger ils facturent
la malibu de +10 et sookie surtout la
baule et la neige déjà il dit
inquiète pas sa reynard in love you man
dans le pays
conçu par
l'employeur de georges lui a fourni deux
itinéraires mais comme plusieurs d'entre
nous il se fie à son gps google maps lui
indique un chemin plus court
au québec il y a près d'un demi million
de kilomètres de chemins forestiers
6000km s'ajoutent chaque année pour
effectuer des coupes forestières ces
chemins apparaissent sur nos gps qui
nous le suggère sans savoir s'ils sont
praticables ou entretenu
voyez sur une carte google maps ou est
parti il est impossible des chercheurs
comme osvaldo valeria et sylvain jutra
sonne l'alarmé sur ses infrastructures
publiques qui tombent en lambeaux n'a
trouvé que 80% du réseau beauty était la
peine entretenu non utilisées et qui
faisait pas l'objet donc d'un d'une
inspection ou d'une amélioration ils
entretiennent une main basse sur la
période où ce que l'exploitation
d'orolia pas ne tienne planifier à long
terme en faisant confiance à son gps
l'infirmier ne pouvait savoir ce qui
l'attendait le chemin asphalté fait
place à un chemin forestier et la nuit
commence à tomber
ces images ont été filmées par djordje
on voit qu'ils n'étaient pas seuls à
être passés par là il y avait des traces
dans la neige comme le montre cette
vidéo découverte plus tard dans son
cellulaire
- tu dit
il dans un chemin une pièce le pays suit
sopi il suit son chemin
après avoir parcouru 70 kilomètres
georgetown sur des panneaux qui
indiquent qu'un pont est fermé mais
l'accès n'est pas bloqué
40% des 2900 points forestiers du québec
sont considérés comme fermer parce
qu'ils sont désuets
mais giorgio n'en a aucune idée il
s'engage et sa camionnette se retrouve
coincé
le début du pont était praticable
c'était pas un pont qui est étrange mais
c'était pratique puis c'était surtout
pas baril je le sais que le pont il n'y
a pas de boules il tombe dans tu tombes
dans l'eau aux fins à la fin il est ici
le en ville je prends mes moyens les
environs je m'équipe praticable toute
son
stand qui peut pas ne peut pas juste
pour halilhodzic en main
devant la menace d'effondrement
l'infirmier quitte son véhicule et se
met à marcher nuitées jours à la
recherche de réseaux cellulaires ou
d'une route passante pour trouver du
secours
son corps je les ai retrouvé huit jours
plus tard à 17 km de sa camionnette
en empruntant cette route forestière
georges était loin de se douter que ce
serait la fin de son propre chemin
pour les gens c'est et un choc de
réaliser ces points de choses qu'on peut
concevoir que quelqu'un soit pays low de
se retrouver coincé labo et de mourir de
froid comme ça
l'entreprise familiale de serge bélisle
qui s'occupe du remorquage dans la
région depuis 50 ans a été appelé sur
les lieux de l'accident il remarque que
rien n'indique à l'entrée de ces chemins
qu'ils sont sans issue
si ces chemins et là ne sont pas
entretenus ni livre ni l'été pourquoi ya
pas une signalisation une fois qu'il est
c'est à l'abandon qu'est-ce qu'on fait
du chemin depuis à qui revient la
responsabilité de bien baliser de
billing and ski ou à ce qu il ya
vraiment un danger
c'est route appartiennent à l'état le
ministère des forêts et responsable du
demi million de kilomètres de chemins
forestiers
le ministère des transports s'occupe de
750 km et les municipalités 290 km pour
le reste l'entretien incombe aux
utilisateurs réguliers et comme la
plupart ne sont que de passage en forêt
il n'ya pas de suivi
[Musique]
la route a été construite utilisés par
l'industrie forestière pour l'extraction
bois pour des travaux sylvicoles volet
travaux sylvicoles fait personne s'en
occupe et loeb il ya personne qui en a
la responsabilité
à part le gouvernement du québec qui a
décidé de le pot dans la sueur et la
responsabilité
deux ans après le drame les proches de
djordje sont persuadés que la négligence
du gouvernement lui a coûté la vie
[Musique]
si ces cheminots sont durs à entretenir
puis que ça coûte cher à l'état pour
lily pour les entretenir tout soit bien
bon lips et où la cnss t qui a enquêté
sur cet accident de travail conclut que
l'infirmier n'aurait pas dû prendre ce
trajet et recommande des mesures pour
les déplacements nordiques mais les
proches de djordje crois qu'elle ne
s'est pas attaqué au coeur du problème
donc pas toucher à l'aspect de sécurité
de la ruhr dépit de tout sauf à parvin
nepentes équipe cpnca livre open sans
manger ça une personne qui s'en va
travailler
dans le rapport on apprend que le
ministère des forêts a fermé le pont
sectionné quatre ans avant l'accident
mais qu'il jugeait inutile d'installer
des entraves parce que des gens peuvent
les déplacer faute d'exploitation
forestière la route n'était pas
entretenu une idée nager et le pont n'a
pas été réparée
on appelle ça une pratique de gestion
par abandon on abandonne simplement le
réseau routier est lui-même
dans les jours suivant la mort de
djordje d'autres camionneurs se sont
enlisées sur la même route google maps a
retiré le tronçon de son application et
les autorités ont bloqué le chemin mais
est ce que les choses ont changé depuis
très peu à mon avis c'est arrivé à des
gens même du coin qui se sont fait
prendre par des ponceaux qui
disparaissent des pompes sont vraiment
dommage et qui ont peu été entretenu par
le temps entre 2011 et 2020 plus de 650
accidents avec blessures ayant fait
l'objet d'un rapport de police sont
survenus sur des chemins forestiers et
36 personnes ayant perdu la vie
[Musique]
dévastation érosion d'instruction des
cours d'eau l'absence d'entretien des
chemins forestiers au québec provoquent
des dégâts environnementaux d'une
ampleur insoupçonnée qui vont s'aggraver
avec les changements climatiques ici sur
la côte nord près du barrage manic 3 ce
chemin a été sectionnée sur une centaine
de mètres c'est un véritable créateur
les ponceaux bloqué par des castors ont
créé de l'érosion faute d'inspection est
l'équivalent de centaines de camions
bennes remplies de gravier se sont
retrouvés dans la rivière
pour considérer que si la négligence ce
qui a causé ce problème là c'est la
négligence de l'entretien et du barrage
de castors et la structure routière et
de notre façon de gérer l'accès au
territoire en milieu forestier
ce qui est arrivé sur la côte nord n'est
pas une surprise pour l'hydrologue
forestier qui a documenté des cas
similaires dans toutes les régions
par souci est ici complètement bloqué la
route est en train de s'affaisser
si l'eau ne peut passer elle déborde
ailleurs et arrachent les routes layton
de contaminants qui se retrouvent dans
nos cours d'eau prix occupe sylvain
jutra qui dénonce le laxisme du
ministère des forêts dans la dernière
année on l'a suivi dans ses démarches kg
a probablement passé en dessous puis
comme vous voyez
il reste plus rien lorsque le chemin est
long il tient un pull
ça passe sous silence parce qu'il n'y a
pas de conséquence majeure mais mettez
ça x 500 et le ponceau sont probablement
peu entretenus sur le territoire
forestier québécois là est le problème
l'ingénieur forestier a porté plainte au
ministère de l'environnement contre le
ministère des forêts concernant cet
autre cas d'érosion dans la réserve
faunique des laurentides
toute l'eau avec le temps au fini par
miner l'ensemble la route quand nous
deux est ce parce que c'est une route
abandonnée la loi sur la qualité de
l'environnement s'applique partout au
québec qui s'applique aux ministères
houcine neuf mois plus tard sa plainte
est toujours en traitement le cas après
de manic 3 lui a été signalé aux
autorités en 2016 mais l'été dernier les
dégâts étaient toujours là le ministère
de l'environnement estime que le
ministère des forêts n'a pas enfreint la
loi on peut pas prétendre qu'on fait de
l'aménagement forestier durable
en fait en dix ans il ne lui a jamais
remis d'infractions concernant l'impact
environnemental des chemins négliger ça
serait bien surprenant qu'elle le
gouvernement du québec poursuivent le
gouvernement du québec
il y aurait plus de 2 millions de
ponceaux au québec mais on ne sait pas
où ils sont ni leurs conditions pour
sylvain jutra c'est clair que le
ministère des forêts ne protège pas
notre eau son équipe a voulu chiffrer
l'étendue des dommages
c'est plus que la moitié des 54 % des
ponceaux qui étaient dans des études
dégradation médiocre où il était même
culot d'autres pays le mal était déjà
fait c'est encore un systémique à
l'échelle de nos forêts publiques on n'a
pas les moyens d'entretenir la totalité
des chemins qui ont été construits par
le passé hugo lapointe fait des audits
de certification forestière à travers le
canada depuis une dizaine d'années et il
constate que le québec accuse un
important retard
le noeud du problème finalement c'est
que on demande à l'industrie forestière
de
de créer des chemins une mois fait il
doit créer des chemins pour accéder à la
forêt à la ressource par contre on ne
donne pas la responsabilité de fermer
ces chemins en fait dans les 15
dernières années soixante dix huit mille
kilomètres ont été construits et à peine
300 km ont été démantelés surtout pour
restaurer l'habitat du caribou qui est
menacée va falloir réparer les erreurs
du passé ça vous coûte une fortune je le
suis mais je vois pas d'autre solution
les générations futures vont payer pour
cette négligence d'anciens
fonctionnaires qui ont requis l'anonymat
nous ont remis des documents qui
prouvent que les autorités connaissent
depuis longtemps les conséquences de
l'abandon des chemins sur
l'environnement et la sécurité
le problème a été pelleter par en avant
de gouvernement en gouvernement depuis
30 ans
alors que québec repoussait les
solutions à plus tard la colombie
britannique elle a décidé d'agir on
s'est donc rendu dans l'ouest pour voir
qui est responsable des chemins
forestiers et comment on les gère
la colombie britannique a de bonnes
prévisions sur les changements
climatiques
[Musique]
qui venait garde sont bien placés pour
nous en parler il travaille pour le
conseil des pratiques forestières de la
colombie britannique qui fait office de
chien de garde des forêts il s'assure
que la loi est respectée notamment pour
l'entretien des chemins
on est une créature du gouvernement
comme vérificateur général ou un
ombudsman des forêts indépendant du
ministère de l'industrie et des groupes
de pression
l'organisme que keven président a été
créé en 1995 pour restaurer la confiance
du public alors que le gouvernement
était accusé d'être à la solde de
l'industrie forestière il traite les
plaintes même des enquêtes fait des audi
et recommande des améliorations au
système
notre tribunal c'est l'opinion publique
généralement quand on rapporte un
problème les responsables le corrigeant
surtout l'industrie qui n'aiment pas
avoir une tache à son dossier sahorre
clos réputation en 1995 la colombie
britannique a aussi changé son régime
forestier est investi deux milliards et
demi de dollars
reconnu qu'il y avait eu 20 ans de
mauvaises pratiques de coupes
forestières de route mal construites qui
tombaient des montagnes qui causaient
des dommages aux cours d'eau et on a
dépensé des centaines de millions de
dollars pour réparer seul aigles
depuis les compagnies forestières ont la
responsabilité permanente des chemins
qu'elle construise et de leur entretien
le gouvernement s'occupe des routes
principales
alors contrairement au québec ici
l'industrie ferme ou démantèle les
routes retire les ponts les ponceaux et
bloque l'accès au chemin dont elle n'a
plus besoin c'est plus écologique et
sécuritaire
non s'il n'y a pas de dépôt de sédiments
pas dommage à l'environnement
côté sécurité les compagnies mettre des
barrières et des panneaux pour avertir
que la route est démantelée
respecte au hasard les ponceaux pour
s'assurer qu'ils ne sont pas bouchés ou
endommagées
1995 il y a eu un virage significatif
les gens font un meilleur travail que le
système n'est pas parfait des traverses
comme celles ci sont encore
problématique pour les poissons
mais les réformes ont permis de mieux
protéger les cours d'eau et les saumons
qui font la réputation de la colombie
britannique
au québec c'est en gaspésie qu'on
retrouve les rivières à saumon
emblématique qui sont des joyaux du
tourisme c'est plus de 40 millions de
retombées économiques par année il ya
environ 500 emplois qui sont reliés avec
l'industrie de la pêche au saumon en
gaspésie et là bas depuis les années 90
on dénonce l'inaction du gouvernement
qui menace l'habitat du roi des poissons
un inventaire qui vient d'être réalisées
prouvent que ça pose en réel danger
il ya jusqu'à 80% des ponceaux qui
montrait de l'érosion importante et
jusqu'à 90% des ponceaux qui était
infranchissable pour le poisson la
moitié de ces traverses en piètre état
sont réparables
mais le nerf de la guerre c'est l'argent
sont suffit juste à l'inventeur qui a
été réalisé on pourrait parler d'environ
5 à 10 millions seul pour le seulement
les bassins versants des rivières de
gaspé pour mettre le réseau à jour
partout au québec il faudrait donc des
milliards le ministère des forêts
rembourse déjà 100 millions par année
pour la construction des chemins
forestiers
tout ce que vous avez installé comme il
n'est pas obtenue ça devient un passé
d'une bête que vous avez pas seulement
parce que vous devez mettre l'argent
pour les mécaniques mais vous c'est une
bête parce qu'il se tournait vers
l'environnement l'industrie forestière
s'en remet au gouvernement la partie qui
nous concerne on s'en occupe on le fait
c'est à l'étang à s'assurer que son
réseau aussi qu'ils soient des chemins
forestiers ou que ce soit des routes
provinciales ou d'aidé aux taureaux qui
soit bien être plus l'industrie est
prête à prendre plus de responsabilités
mais à condition de revoir le système je
pense que c'est l'objet d'une discussion
profonde qu'on va devons faire dans les
prochains jours dans les prochaines
années
en 2004 le rapport coulon me
recommandait la fermeture des chemins
comme en colombie britannique à cause
des impacts déjà bien connu sur les
écosystèmes
on est condamné à régler le problème
sinon un moment donné ça va être notre
région c'est avec nos rivières nos
poissons qui vont en payer le prix
en 2010 le forestier en chef déploré
l'ampleur du réseau abandonné et
recommandé d'établir clairement les
responsabilités du ministère de
l'industrie forestière et des autres
utilisateurs
douze ans plus tard les intervenants
insistent il y a urgence d'agir on
pourra pas régler le problème xi a pas
de volonté politique pour la régler
le cabinet du ministre des forêts nous a
dit qu'une réflexion est en cours pour
élaborer une éventuelle politique de
gestion des chemins sans fournir
d'échéances y est et que la fermeture de
ces chemins pose un défi d'acceptabilité
sociale
pour l'infirmier giorgi mort dans des
circonstances tragiques il est
malheureusement trop tard mais ses
proches souhaitent des changements
rapides pour que pareils drames ne se
reproduisent jamais
e
[Musique]